if you never seen pie test or unit
testing you'll find this the idea for
this talk is to get you over the hump
where you don't know what it's about and
you don't know how to run it to a point
where you feel comfortable enough with
it to move on with more advanced
tutorials that are going on so I will
and so I don't want you at any one time
if you're looking for a super advanced
PI test tutorial this is this is not it
this is getting getting started and
getting familiar with unit testing all
right so let's do the traditional about
the speaker and all that other stuff so
about me I work at SpaceX I taught a
bootcamp here for six months so these
two awesome girls were in my class
philately little Linda lots if you think
I'm a terrible speaker you go complain
to them they had to deal with this for
six months so they'll they'll be
commiserate is with you I contribute a
lot to RVs that's gonna become relevant
later with testing and we're happy that
y'all came to PI data so I'm one of the
committee members from PI data so thank
you all for coming to this conference
the first year that I did is this it
it's fantastic that you found it and you
took the time on a Sunday to come out
and I super encourage everyone to come
back on Monday and Tuesday as well when
we have our keynote speakers and the
rest of the talks we have a social event
tomorrow we have lightning talk so if
you didn't get a chance to submit
something and you still want to come and
talk with that that's available as well
I want to give a shout out Nathan
Danielson is in the back he is he's the
primary chair one of the three and he
spent a lot of we weeks and weekends
getting this going as well so go shake
his hand he's a great guy we just get
hold of me you have my my LinkedIn and
all that and then disclaimer everything
is my own opinion I don't represent
anyone else but myself in this talk so
we'll get that out of the way the other
thing I want to say is you guys will be
doing the majority of this tutorial I
well I'm gonna pause for like 30 or 40
minutes a cumulative over the the time
this talk we're year's gonna be coding
so you know otherwise we'll just be
staring at each other awkwardly for 10
minutes if you don't clone this repo and
install the dependency so super
encourage everyone to to get a copy of
this repo PI test for data science
there's actual activities we're going to
go through and so prevent it from being
boring
let's do that I'm so the I would clone
this and I would install the
dependencies some of you probably have
them installed they're pandas high-test
and requests pretty small ones but do a
pip - are so let me let me jump in the
next section tutorial format so why am i
doing it this way why do I sort of
believe in this method so git clone
install requirements how this will go
I'm gonna just conceptually talk through
PI test a little bit so it'll be a
little abstract I'll wave my hands and
then we're gonna just dive right into
concrete stuff I'll show you an example
and then you guys are gonna try it out
this is super similar to the bootcamp
format which I found super effective I
want everyone to find a partner in this
and I see people sitting alone and I'm
not going to have that because this is a
conference and we want you guys to
network and meet other people as
diversity coach here I want people to
meet other people of different
backgrounds but there's also there's
also real reason to this well this is
not just the like let's be buddies type
of thing it turns out when you're when
you pair up with somebody yeah I'll give
you say yeah go ahead and review cig
Risa so the reason I'm making you
awkwardly introduce yourself is well one
you're at a conference so I make you
know you signed up for this a little bit
but it actually makes you learn if
there's loma linda has a has a effective
ways of learning and and we're gonna go
through all of them we're gonna learn
multiple ways I'm going to I'm going to
show you I want to talk about it I'm
going to show you in code and you're
gonna do it yourself we're gonna build
examples from each other and the biggest
one why I want you guys to sit next to
each other is if you teach somebody else
so I'm gonna be teaching you but you're
gonna learn more if you then work with
your partner and you guys both teach
each other I think the knowledge and the
retention will be there so my goal is
not to just give you a bunch of
information my goal is to have you guys
actually be able to use PI tests by the
end of it so you're not gazing I feel
like a lot of tutorial sometimes you're
dazed and confused at the end I don't
want that to happen I want you to feel
secure in your knowledge about what's
going on so let's do Y testing and we'll
talk about that so why do we bother with
testing things at all so I do data
I see type stuff one of the data science
things that I do is I go to dinner with
my girlfriend or whatever and then I
want to split the bill up it's a data
science problem I've been in foot I'm
also kind of cheap and don't wanna keep
paying for hair so I want to cut it in
half and I wrote a function to do that
because you know we have computers why
do it do I do it myself
so the function is really simple and I'm
gonna use VI a lot for because vim is
just a text editor that's happens to be
the console so this is my function I
have a Python function split bill it
takes input cost take the cost I divided
by two and then I'm just going to print
the cost so I know how much to you how
much this bill is and then that's about
it so it should be pretty simple I take
this one
Python bill split two point five dollars
mean surprises he was amazing
nope crazy nothing crazy will do this
anything over here
two dollars it's the same function does
anyone want to guess why what happened
exactly the same huh yes yeah
but I'm running Python right yeah so
it's the same command Python dual split
yeah weird huh a little different yes
somebody got it python 2 versus python 3
so when I flip side flip the screens
python this ones 2.7 and this one is 3
and I know this like where it means like
2019 everyone should get on board Python
3 what did someone crazy but it's
there's differences on it with code
right you write code on your computer
and it works and you're like cool I
wrote this awesome function let me just
give it to my coworker or let me we're
done focus all but open source let me
open source this thing suddenly somebody
else is running your code and nothing
works I guess does anyone agree that
division is the thing we do in data
science seems like common yeah so you
would want your division to be correct
and if I wrote my library in Python 3
and I my bill split function works
correctly
if I give it to somebody else there
that's everything's gonna be off like
you're known that so can we officer
division they're your classifier is
gonna be off your mat plot Lib bars are
gonna be like everything is just wrong
so the point of testing is that you're
supposed to write down what you expect
and let's let's go through our first
test so oh by the way questions who who
answered you answering yeah okay you get
your chance your Kit Kat Reese's
Hershey's Hershey's they got almond and
you got normal only yeah well who got
2.73 you got something all right you
guys are you guys also gonna find out
that I'm a nerd and don't play sports so
I hope look hit someone in the face
yeah the facts that I'll hit you with a
candy bar but I were welcome to add
questions they're super encouraged I
will gladly throw sugar your way yes
where did they live okay good point
so me I mean particularly anaconda to
split my environments up so I I used my
condo package manager and I have in this
in this computer I have six versions of
the Python from anaconda then there's
two from from the Mac by the way and if
you go to user bin Python this is a
little bit off the Taco Bell go with it
this is the this is the version of
Python that's built into your Mac and
there's actually two there's Python 3
and there's Python that's Python 2
that's in Mac OS this is I guess I don't
have a Python 3 in this one so I have at
least seven on this computer this is a
little bit of site will go with it it's
with Python it's important to split your
environments up so there's there's
virtually envy is one way of doing this
another way of doing this is Conda
that's my favorite so I used anaconda
versioning and then you have docker
containers are really popular so there's
there's actually doctor talk happening
right now doctor provides a layer of
isolation and then the Hat most
heavyweight one is VM but that's how I
step how I split
my Python environment at work I have
like 26 of these because I have 26
different projects that I work on I hope
that helps so this one was activated
this one should have been the this is
3/5 yeah this one it's a 2 7 you can see
the difference here 3 5 and then 2 7 and
this one's the PI data environment and
this is just my normal route environment
it's cool all right you get something to
you that's good question ok all right
you wanted to me a favor you wanna help
me pass like I tell people okay a great
question yeah so it is a that's but the
point is people have different versions
of Python and the computer is like
there's there's a lot of difference of
Python but you say Python that's there's
at least two seven and then within two
seven there's minor and major Reds then
you have 3 1 3 2 3 4 3 5 3 6 and minor
versions between you have to be it you
have to be sure that your code runs on
on the ones that you support right so
that's why we write tests so I'm going
to show you that let's talk about why
testing how much time do I have
I should probably keep a lot of yeah
okay alright so notes I put some notes
in here too so you guys I have to
memorize what I'm saying I might talk a
little bit faster to get so python 2
versus python 3 let's talk about what is
a bug wow if my computer wants to
cooperate with me alright so what is a
bug it's an error flaw or failure in a
computer program one of my programmer
had a bug in it it's not on python t7
you get the wrong answer so that's a bug
in my program it is not a bug in Python
because python was designed with that
explicitly so python 2 does not have a
bug that's the way python 2 works if you
divide 5 by 2 you get you don't get 2.5
you get to language design choice it's
documented the bug is in my program
where I'm using it to do a thing and
it's not doing the thing that I wanted
to do so testing helps catch bugs so the
reasons the motivation yeah testing
helps catch bugs we're gonna see that in
a second I'll show you the exactly the
example we just saw but the other two
benefits of testing is that they help
users understand the program
and they help with code development
refactoring so these two will become a
little bit more apparent as I show you
some examples so let's jump into basic
testing examples all right so let's do
let's go back to my single bash pain or
see you go for okay
so in my test I have test bill split and
what I'm doing here is this is this is
the first structure for a PI test
program the structure is you bring in
the code that you want to test so in
this case I want to test my bill split
module you then write a function and the
function as a just has to say test
somewhere in it so in this case I have
test underscore in the front and I'm
testing Bill splitting it doesn't have
to be the same I could make this test
bill splitting whatever but the
important part is that test is right
here in the front I have a I have a doc
string because you know doctrines are
good and then what I'm doing is I'm I'm
writing my function and then I'm writing
an assert statement down here that says
the split is equal to 2.5 that's what I
want out of my program yes sir PI test
does not require imports so this is a
really good we'll go into we'll go into
the different testing libraries in a
second this is a PI test style test so
they are deep I thought as a number of
different testing style sometimes this
is where Python fails that the one
obvious way of doing things but there's
other ones we'll talk about that in a
second this is just this is just five
tests so let's run let's run the test so
the way I run the test as I run PI test
test bill split WI and run it and I get
my air and I get two equals 2.5 this is
good
because we're on Python 2 so if I run
this in Python 3 high test test they'll
split
yeah well o source activate whoops
source activate root
this works this is good because one test
when I run it in one environment I get a
nice hair message that tells me I have a
failure this test failed to is not equal
to 2.5 my search fail in Python 3 you
can see it right here actually it even
prints it for you this is Python 2 this
is Python 3 it runs the dot means that
it passed and it's a little unintuitive
and I'll make this a little more verbose
if you like if you like to read and see
that it's really passing you it's an
English language you can put a minus V
flag run - me and it'll it'll tell you
explicitly that this passed this is the
test this is the test module this is the
test function and this passed so where
this is a let me pull up the reading for
this thing I'll show you how this works
in practice so in practice you run a PI
test by running it like this in open
source this is actually how it runs we
when I want to contribute to open source
and either PI mc3 your rv's or whatever
if you look at this graphic we're
testing across two seven four two three
one two three four five six seven pi 2.7
both in 32-bit and 64-bit versions and
3.6 and we have both 64 a 3.6 we're only
testing in 64 so not only testing python
version we're also testing the bit of
the iPhone so 32-bit 64-bit versions of
Python this is to make sure that that it
works across every single supported
version of Python PI test will run in
the default so this is but this is a
good argument to make sure don't have
super messy environments isolate your
environment so then there's only one
version in each one so this is this is
where I super messy environment but this
is a good reason this is where super
messy environments will hurt you the
code will work on your computer and it
will only work on your computer because
there's some magical combination of
dependencies that somehow conforms into
being the thing that makes your code
running and will never run on anyone
elses computer and you can't it'll be
hard to make around anyone elses
computer so
it is what this is a good maybe quick CI
thing and let me actually pull up an RV
seat I'll use Arby's because it's my
it's the library that I contribute to
I'll show you how this sort of works
github.com go to Arby's so I'll be doing
a lightning talk on Arby's later it's a
library for doing Bayesian in Bayesian
model criticism so if you had a Bayes
theorem there's there's libraries out
there to make Bayesian models it's a
type of machine learning and then you
have to evaluate the models and so these
is a library that has a lot of plots and
whatnot to help you evaluate the models
we want to make sure that this runs over
a lot of people's computers so what we
do and I'm gonna go all the way into you
actually won back all the way into my CI
engine and in rvs in Travis CI every
time we make a commit to master or
commit in the and the make a push to the
repo travesty I sees that and it runs
tests across three five and thirty six
RVs only supports three five and thirty
six and we're actually running across
two versions of stamp in here when you
open this up and you look at the job log
it's going through and it's running a
hundred and no two hundred twenty unit
tests and this is actually a small
project if you look if you try to test
pandas it's got thousands of tests so
this is why we test we want to make sure
RVs works not on our computers on all
the people who want to use our visas
computers that's the motivation behind
testing so this is the end of the
theoretical section does anyone have any
questions or feel like testing is still
a waste of time don't need it any quick
any in this yeah
okay so you're running that's a good
point if you're running if using a
docker image your your environment is
the same right because docker isolates
the environment for you but does doctor
guarantee that your code is correct so
that's why you still want to test so
this is when people say about
test-driven development well one one one
point of testing is to you know that it
runs across all environments in this
case we don't need it with docker but
the other point is you write code and
your code can have a bug in it you don't
know about it testing helps you catch
those bugs there's another class by the
way people this is a little more
theoretical there's a whole notion that
in software the moment where some people
think that if you write tests you end up
writing better code so if you write
tests first and then you write your code
your code is better than if you write
code first and then test later this
that's the arguments back and forth
about test-driven development but that's
probably the farthest reason I'd say the
test the first two are makes you make
sure it runs across all environments the
second is that you know your code works
for sure actually in the third that I
think that is nice is that if you look
at the if you look at the code we'll go
back to and I'm flipping all over the
place if you look at the code it
actually makes it easy to tell what's
supposed to happen so my test split bill
code actually when you read this now if
somebody can sort of tell what it's
supposed to do because it's it's one
example of it in action so testing helps
new people understand your code base -
all right so this is where I stop
talking and I let you guys run your
first test so I'm gonna admit all the
solutions are in this solve folder you
can do your you can cheat and look at it
first but I love it you'll you'll
probably learn less so my advice to you
is try doing it yourself and banging
your head against the wall for just a
little bit and then if you're really
stuck we'll go through this solution so
what I want you guys to do is I want you
to just to be consistent I'd want you
guys to navigate to this directory oh
whoops went back too far it is labeled
activity so everything labeled activity
is things you're going to do I want you
to write a test to make sure this outer
function works correctly
I which it's a it's a five in here what
I want you guys to do is write write a
PI test file yourselves that verifies
that this add function actually does
addition addition correctly so this add
function there's any I guess does anyone
want me to demonstrate the add function
it's easy enough okay if anyone has
questions about about how to use the
outer function let me know but I want
you to write a I'm not gonna show you
the answer but uh this is this is the
test bill split function I want you to
write one that's like test add and make
sure that adding works works well and
I'll give you guys like ten minutes to
do it ah the font okay while you guys
are doing the activity I will also
change my terminal font size because it
takes a little bit of effort but
otherwise the code is all online if you
get it on github it's everything is
there so everything you see me doing is
on the github repo alright I get her
repo is um let me pull it up is this
readable how about that that there we go
the first the fun part is github calm
and then this is the actual like part
that matters I mean am I using PyCharm I
don't know what I'm using oh now I'm
using the regular camera I think I have
to go and change it I will do that
alright well well look at that perfect
all right
so ten minutes I'll give you two about
two o'clock so good
discussing trying to figure it out you
got this Tiffany it's normal right you
just way back like I forgot to do myself
all right who asked questions are good
guess on candy candy candy no you're not
stupid
all right so okay so oh you want to run
the test okay no no okay so if you want
to if you want to use outer okay that's
fair I should have put an example you
know that you have to do I just know
that's okay VI work so I'll make one for
you real quick I should have this was an
oversight on my part in the next one
ones will have it I don't know how to
use
okay VI has a really high learning curve
so don't worry about it if name equals
no no that's a good point you should
know what it does to test it like that
is the exact mentality you could have
almost done print I would stick a Python
no you what you have is like I shouldn't
use that it was right there oh boy okay
so now this will this will actually it's
a two plus five is it yeah so what's
happening is when you run this function
it you get seven yeah and so it's we're
like cool that's correct now just what
you do is try and write there's a new
file is they write a test that does it
okay that's all yeah so fair point
copying and pasting from the previous
one is not cheating you can just copy
the test from the other example and then
just modify it to work that is totally
fine writing code from scratch is a
waste of time it's great to just copy
code that exists and make it work for
you
yeah
which is you've cannon I mean I okay so
just try Python hmm oh well I mean I
can't oh you need pie test oh did you
saw it yeah you need pie oh so you guys
will definitely have to install pie test
it's not a built-in it's a it's a
something you need to install so you
need to you guys definitely need to pip
install pie test for pie test to work
and then for this lecture I go into
pandas and requests as well which also
need to be pip or content salted
whatever it might be and I have about
two more minutes
running from the console I would run it
from the console it's just running oh I
see what's mine okay I'll explain what's
going on here second all right okay yes
okay see it's not Python actually that's
a good point I see what's going on okay
so we had the same question a bunch of
times which I'm happy because you guys
are trying but we're getting the same
problem so for the purpose of this
tutorial let's go through it and I'll
show you I'll show you the common
mistake that you guys are making and
then we'll I'll show you how to work
this so in my case I'll run the bill
split one first I shall just run the ad
I run the Beltsville try thing yeah I
did this one okay so the bill split when
you guys type in Python test bill split
you get nothing right nothing excessive
this is the first this is probably the
first mistake where I got frustrated
with PI test if you try running this
this Python program under Python it
doesn't do anything because Python
doesn't see anything to do you define a
function and nothing happened all right
the trick is you have to run it through
PI tests so you don't type in Python
because then Python runs the file and
Python does sees that there's nothing to
do you have to run it through PI test
which is actually the program that reads
it in and does a bunch of stuff that's a
really good question it's the first
hurdle I have with PI test that and it
confused me forever actually keeps me
like a good three or four hours before
like I finally stumbled upon it
yes yeah that's not how high test runs
that's an interest that the good point
so tests don't take arguments because
they're isolated so each test is
self-contained and PI test has its own
test discovery so this is good this is
why this is why I want you guys to try
things for us because we when you make
mistakes and you feel really embarrassed
and it like it's really painful and you
remember high school and you don't want
to live that experience over again now
you're gonna remember how PI test works
so there was a really good question when
you run this like why despite the how
this practice and know how to do
anything all right and where are the
arguments well one if you're really unit
if you're quote unquote truly unit
testing each each function is completely
independent from every other function so
we're gonna let me show you are B's or
actually I'll show you I'll show this
near the end but each usually test don't
take arguments tests test a specific
amount of code and then assertion and
then you're out
you don't actually provide anything
there's in real code you do have to
provide something there's ways to fake
it out we're gonna get into ways to fake
out functions later but you're not
testing your whole library in one shot
you're testing tiny sections of code and
you're you're building up all it's like
like testing a car or whatever you don't
test it on the road you build these
fixtures that hold it and then you test
one component the way PI test works is
PI test looks for every function or a
class if you if you're familiar with the
action unit style testing that has
tested in then either the front of the
back and if it has tests in the front of
the back PI test recognizes it as a test
and runs it so even though I don't
directly call this function the way PI
test is written it it it does what's
called test discovery and gets the test
I think I wrote so I tried putting a
helpful reading ease in everywhere I
could so let me go through this one the
documentation for how this works is
right here oh shoot it's not okay I will
add that as a readme but really not sad
didn't okay yeah so your first test run
it with PI tests and I will I will add
in the the link to PI test auto
discovery but if you type in PI test
test
right here the first link will be how
the documentation on the full
documentation on how high test works
you'll see that this documentation is
really long this is why I made the
tutorial otherwise we'll spend like a
week trying to go through the
documentation and pick out the relevant
parts I just want I'm gonna get you to
the point that works and you're gonna
have this whole world the documentation
to help you out yes ma'am so the
question justice in the Mike is that
when there is a hundred things that
could go wrong with your code how do you
know which ones detest so it's not fair
I the answer is and this is this is
where people get in a lot of arguments
online the the answer I want to give you
is what's reasonable like a reasonable
amount of test for your code and I'll
preface in two ways there's some people
I think you have to test everything so
there's this thing called hundred
percent test coverage and then if
anyone's ever heard this concept but
there's some companies have this thing
where every every line of your coat
every code every line of your code has
to be tested so and it's got to be at a
hundred percent so I'll go back to RV's
when we're testing code
we're running we're running a test over
portion of our code so I'm gonna go
through Python because it'll be a little
easier to show so when we're testing
this outer function for instance in this
case we're testing a hundred percent of
our code but I could have another
function in here that's like test def
subtract and then I say num1 and then um
- and then I don't test it I'll just say
something I don't test it I just test
one function and your question was I'm
if I'm testing this some way but I'm not
testing that another way you
you should write enough tests to what
you think is reasonable in in this case
I provide a number input so it works if
I provided string inputs it wouldn't
work so then I ask myself two questions
if this is an internally facing function
two people that are from like familiar
with Python and in the middle of the
library I will I'm assuming they there
I'm gonna say they're more familiar with
how Python works and I can assume
they'll use it correctly and I'll write
just the test of functionality so maybe
one test but if I'm writing test for
something at the user interface level
there's a lot of users online they don't
know how my library works they can be at
varying different skill levels so then
I'll write a lot of tests to test
everything they could possibly throw at
it
so like things that are public like it's
your car right when you when you go to
your car your car's an interface right
then you got a nice steering wheel and
everything like that and everything is
good as soon as you dive one level in
you take your dash up or you bring your
hood it's suddenly a lot more confusing
because the designers of your car where
it's where it's uh it's meant for
everybody it's nice you've got cup
holders you got steering wheel you got
your stereo that's all good as soon as
you get one level of abstraction lower
into your engine it's a lot more
confusing and at that point they're
assuming that you're a mechanic or a car
expert and so I write a lot of tests for
at the user interface level where I
expect a lot of people to work and I
write less tests as I go down into the
code where I expect a more people that
are more familiar with the code to be at
that's officially into question
I feel like good okay yes yeah that's
fair but what I do with my bills for
example what do I put the assertion
there you can't because it's the it's
the Python code itself that's running it
poorly so there's not I can't write in a
search for the for the value that I want
to get so that's the reason for testing
that's another reason that's a good
question the other reason you don't have
you don't have put assertions maybe in
your code is it clutters up your cut so
testing if you put off a billion
assertions your code to test for
everything in your code you'll have like
20 certs to make sure it's a string it's
an integer it's above 1 if it's square
root all this and then you have like one
line to actually do this the addition if
you write your test you can leave your
test you can leave your function has to
be
simple and all the extra testing stuff's
on the outside so it's easier to
maintain over time as well I think
that's another it's another good reason
okay so in the interest of time I will
barrel on so let's let's do this
basic guiding let me show you the the
answer for the adding example um so I'm
gonna just copy okay so I've added my
test function right next to this so I'll
actually show it to you in PyCharm
because it's gonna be a little easier to
see here's my adder here's my test dad
and I'm we're actually running two cases
I'm adding yeah I'm sorry about this I'm
adding two and three and I should get
five and then I'm adding two and
negative three and I'll get negative one
to your point I'm not testing a string
input if somebody use this library and
they put a string and put it and it
failed that'd be on me because I didn't
adequately write enough tests so the way
you run this and I'll do it the wrong
way first if you run Python test add py
nothing's nothing's gonna happen
I guess Python will look at this there's
nothing to run it's just function
declarations just to exit doubt I want
to run it as a PI test file so I do test
dad and I'll get I messed up my code as
I was talking so this is a good example
one of my tests passed and then I
screwed up my code while I was talking
to you guys and now it doesn't work so
when I stuck my second my second test
failed so I'm gonna fix it and then
we're gonna run it again I think that
saved a I run it now two dots cool if
you want the extra verbosity you put
minus V and you get T test testing cases
I would think about is it's does the
code work at all did I did I actually
implement my ad incorrectly because you
can implement your adding incorrectly
like what if I have my outer function
and I accidentally add I add one because
I don't know I'm tired and it's late I
want to go home and sleep suddenly my
codes not working it's not adding things
together correctly so that's one version
one reason to test another reason to
test is it's for Python versions it's to
make sure it's the biggest things that
make sure your code works the second one
it's
cross compatibility the third one is it
helps people understand what your
library is doing so when somebody sees
this they can the lis see some examples
of how your code is working so for
developers it makes it makes it easier
to see what's the expected and put the
extra goblin actually in the last one I
forgot this the biggest reason to test
so I should need the jump is all the way
back on the front for refactoring your
code so your code will work at one point
in time but then you'll keep editing it
and you'll accidentally introduce a bug
testing make sure it's what's called
there's no regressions in your code so
regression testing which is a subset of
what real testing is to make sure your
code keeps doing the right thing even
though you keep adding more and more
features to it that's actually sorry
that should just leave Lud with that
that's the primary reason for testing so
it's how pandas keeps working even
though there's a crap ton of developers
because you have tests to make sure that
the code still functions the way you
want it to function if and the opposite
is for people that are usually new to
Python they do Python they do a bunch of
print statements and then they wash it
all and then they delete the print
statements well if you go any modify
your code you don't know if those it
still works because you're not looking
at all the print statements again make
sense all right
so let's ramp up another another level
so I'm gonna show you this is everyone
actually before I move on does anyone
feel confused about testing at least how
to run a Python
okay because we're gonna go up one more
level of difficulty it's gonna match it
up I'll use a this is this readable no
ELISA directory structure okay so in in
in most production projects let's use
pandas for example I'll use ivories
first and then I use pandas you don't
actually put your tests right next to
your code so in this example our tests
were right next to our code so in this
one here's my test here's my code this
is not how most projects look what they
do is they usually put the test in a
different directory for for keeping your
projects clean so I'm gonna show you
this in pandas and RVs to show you the
real thing and in pandas I have my
top-level repository you can see here's
all the code that goes into pandas the
actual module the actual module is right
here and right here I have all my tests
away from all the other libraries so
here's there's a directory called test
and in here you have tests for arrays
computation everything else pandas has a
whole bunch of tests and arvy is the
same thing our code our topple over
repository is where this package is so
this is the RV's package in here there's
a directory called test in here we have
all of our tests that test out our our
functionality so tests are usually
separated from code and uh normally on
all production projects if you look at
x-ray or any numpy the same deal why I'm
explaining this to you is because in in
the next example this is what we're this
is what we were doing I'm splitting out
the tests from the actual code to
declare that they're actually our tests
so if I go to the fixtures example I go
to my library my tests are in here are
in here they're in a different folder
then then my module so my module is the
actual module it's the pandas of the
RV's or the numpy or the matplotlib of
the world and then my tests are in the
directory called test this is very great
typical of testing libraries
so bring this over Oh
why this thing is always gonna fill me
alright we're gonna use pycharm to show
this thing to you so again there's a
readme uh should bring it up on github
but yeah bring it up on github okay
sorry I know I'm all over the place well
get their fixtures example ok just read
me the concepts we're gonna test module
in directory structure that's one I'm
gonna show you
fixtures and then we already did PI test
flags in here again there's the entire
documentation for that coverage even
more of what I'm gonna cover so let's
run this test same deal so in this case
my library is the directory right here
in here there's my module is this piece
of code right here all I'm doing is
loading data so here's where the data
science component comes in sometimes
when you load data in for things it
takes a really long time so large data
sets can take like minutes or hours to
load and you don't want to it's annoying
to keep doing it over and over again so
this is my data loading function it's
it's sleeps for three seconds because I
have a a ton of data and then it returns
five I want to test this thing to make
sure that it works so what I can do
whoops
boom tests and I slow and I'll explain
why it's gonna be slow in a second I'm
gonna test my function right so I'm
gonna import PI tests and I'll explain
why in a second but we'll leave that
there the next thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to import my code so this is a
Python relative import so from two
directories up I'm going to import the
my module the code Python has absolutely
imports and relative imports usually
tests that are contained inside of a
test directory are relative because
you're importing the code that's two
directories up this you can ignore me if
this doesn't make any sense I'll explain
it for a little more advanced
instructions in Python the important
machinery if I did import pandas or
import RVs here it would not import the
one it would import the first one it
finds in the suspec
import discovery which might be in a
different environment than the one that
you're in so you might be testing a
different version of pandas then
one that you're trying to test the
reason why this is important I I have
three versions of arteries on my
computer at any point in time I have the
production version and then I have two
different divisions and I want to make
sure I'm testing the correct version so
if I do if I do absolutely imports if I
say input RV's I don't know which one of
the three it's importing I mean I do
because I know how Python works but you
could easily screw it up so sometimes I
don't and then I think I'm doing my
cousin great then I upload it and then
my fellow contributors are like what the
hell you screwed up the codebase so I do
relative import to make sure I'm getting
the right thing there's three tests in
here
so the question before the prefix buy
test so I've test test not three test
object is an integer and test justice
five so I felt like in this case we
should test three things because you
know I don't know like three things with
the thing to do I want to test that it's
not it's not three so shouldn't be three
because it's five I want to test that
it's an integer type so in data science
you're loading in lots and lots of
information if you guys can use like
scikit-learn or whatever you throw an
integer or you throw a string and an
integer column and the regression just
throws up and you've wasted like an hour
that happens all the time so let's test
data types and then I just want to make
sure it's five so I'm gonna run this so
directory LS so I'm in this case gonna
run PI test my library and then test so
when you when you do your example in
like the five minutes this is the
function you're gonna run because you're
gonna run the tests that are located in
in the my library function I'm gonna run
this and we're gonna let this go yeah
let's go oh shoot I know what I did
wrong
whoops right example so I'm gonna run
actually just I just went on run of them
and this is a little contrived but I'll
explain why in a second so I'm just
going to run the test slow function
sorry the test slow module I'm gonna run
it and it takes in this case it took 9.0
four seconds so it's super slow so I'll
have someone do maths for me anyone want
to volunteer just free candy if you
volunteer why do you think it's took
nine seconds yes
yes I have three test cases and because
I'm reloading the data every time I'll
just bring it up over here because I'm
reloading the data every time it takes
three seconds to run each time so in
this case time sleep is three I ran
three tests you have nine seconds and
then you have point oh four seconds for
the overhead of high test right that's
annoying when you run a lot of tests
it's a pain to keep doing the same thing
over and over again I'm literally just
wasting time so if I was testing data
loads if I loved the data in every
single time I want to run every single
test the tests will take hours and then
nobody runs the test and then there's no
point to testing in the first place so
this is the motivation behind fixtures
let me show you what a fixture looks
like so in tests here's test slow
there's no fixtures in here here's
another version of height test and this
one's gonna be a little confusing so
let's talk through it and then I'll show
you the difference or did someone want
to see the result the sum want to see
the results first and then I'll show you
the difference all right results first
this test took nine seconds I'm gonna
run a PI test oops and then I'm going to
test test save time with fixture and I
know we're getting a little safe okay
test save time with fixture I run this
and it's gonna run in probably 3.0 four
seconds 3.0 three seconds here's here's
a test with fixture
here's test slow so test slow has three
functions one two three test safe time
with fixture also has three one two
three they're the exact same test I test
that five isn't three that result
fixtures is not an integer and this
equals five the way I'm saving time is
I'm only loading the data once through a
fixture so fixtures syntax and PI test
is a little confusing so what it what
you do is you you write a function and
you call it you can call you don't have
to call it a fixture but you call it
something you have it do the really
expensive slow operation so this is the
the really slow thing and then you have
it return the result and then with all
the other functions you give it you give
it an argument that's called result
fixture and what this does is it passes
this result over here and then and then
does your test you have to import PI
test here so this is where you have to
import PI test to get access to a PI
test
so there's a lot of the if I go through
all the advanced I'm gonna say all the
advanced Python words that you can
immediately ignore but you're gonna
relative imports are good this is called
the decorator this is the fixture
function and then I'm passing fixture as
an argument to these other fixtures and
then this stuff and in plain speak just
add this thing at the top of your code
that says high test out fixture it means
this will run in this case once and I'll
explain in a second why and then it'll
it'll save this result and give it to
these three functions so it loads the
data once for three seconds and then
runs three tests yes you could and I'll
explain the scoping in a second so for
now I'm just gonna leave you to you guys
to just know to just take this as magic
when I say scope equals session and then
I'll explain after you've done the
activity with what the scoping means I
don't know I know I've been talking for
like 15 minutes and this is where people
start zoning out so with that I would I
want you guys to do is I want you to try
the next example
and here's what's gonna happen in the
next example I want you to test this
this function or this object so you can
ignore all this code but there's one
trick here if you if you try and make
this object twice the second load is
gonna take a minute so the trick here is
you need to write a fixture so you can
write two tests for this object but only
run at one time that's the point of
fixtures any questions on why this is
this contrived but I wrote it in a way
that forces you to do it this way
otherwise I know what would happen you
just write it twice and you miss the
point does anyone have a question why I
read this way or what it's any you will
get is you will get really fast
you'll get one second if you try if you
try running this object twice though
you're gonna end up getting one minute
because the second time it loads it's
gonna take a minute to load so if it's
already was created it's gonna sleep for
a minute before it finishes this time if
you want to see what it does you can run
it so I'll here I'll give you an example
I'll run the code to should give you an
example what's gonna happen so CD CD o7
so if I run Python my library so I'm
going to actually run this I'm not gonna
run a pie test Python my library
by module it used the object only once
it this was nearly instantaneous if I
tried doing this again though and I say
print finished again I'm gonna make this
a little bit less because I don't want
you to stare at me for a minute
but I'll make this five seconds the
first one will be incident and the
second one is going to take five seconds
before loads so this is where you don't
want to do a thing twice what I want you
guys to do is use a PI test fixture to
test this and the test should take less
than a minute and I want you to test
that adding still works that I can I can
give this thing a number and then I can
give it a number in another number and
then it does the adding so see ya I'll
give you 10 minutes to give a give that
a try so we'll get will end it t 30 or
231 yeah
again copying and pasting code from the
previous example not cheating totally
valid
yeah the fixture isn't method me oh you
can have anything yeah your fish give me
anything it doesn't have to be called
results picture it can be called
whatever you want to be
and I'll bring up the just see okay
since you guys have laptops this is the
this is the example so you can use this
as a guide admittedly by the way it
helps have two screens when you're
testing because you get one screen is
your code the other screen is your
testing so you can look back and forth
it's a little hard doing it sideways
getting it on one one small laptop
screen definitely doesn't give
questioning I'm sorry I answered it in a
kind of vague way but did it make sense
for your code is that people that are
outside of the company that are working
around or inside yeah that's a good one
okay so yes that's a really good use I
forgot operating system but yeah same
thing so and as much do you think is
reasonable because if you had an
infinite time then you test everything
well like you can read like 50 you could
write a 50 test to test like a square
root function like the ad [ __ ] you can
test everything right eventually you
could test really big energy it'll cause
memory overflows like I tested for
memory overflows but like who's gonna do
that you know I mean like you're gonna
sit at work for like a zillion hours and
write a thousand tests yeah but I will
say the other way I do it if I'm being
lazy is I write like a minimal amount of
tests and then if when somebody messes
something up and like it causes a
problem then I write a test like cover
that one like a another to keep writing
band-aid tests and then over time I'm
like okay I've got all the things that
like normally get caught
well probably will have me yeah I don't
know it's like it's like seatbelts and
cars after in cars you know the first
cars are really crappy and is just ran
into things and over time they learned
like oh we should put an airbag here and
we should put in there back there and
we'll have it everybody got here and now
we're we're like safe but it took a lot
of car crashes for that to happen it's
like it's sort of a similar thing with
code
got it make me proud
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yes for the outer class yes so so
I'm making
so I'm making one of your objects
[Music]
add more does that change its number in
just returns number it's very close
you're really you're really close you're
like one line up you get that you get
the gist to it see you're good
oh yeah exactly
so these fixtures have a question I got
is what a fixture is used for fixtures
are used for the biggest using reason to
use fixtures is to save computation so
if you're running out if you're running
I'll give you an example from rvs it's a
Bayesian computer computation library
doing Bayesian running a Bayesian model
so it could take like five minutes or
more but we want to test the model I
don't want to run one model every single
time we got to run a test so I run the
model once and then we just reuse that
model over and over and over again and
PI test ensures that it's just there and
available there's there's more there's
more advanced uses for fixtures I'm not
gonna get I won't go into in this basic
talk but there's the link will tell you
barbata
so we good there all right I'm gonna
show you the I've run the example and
I'll show you how it works so alright so
vim test outer solve so in this case I
instantiate the fixture one time and
then I and then I run this twice so
here's the fixture it instantiate s' the
object and then I reuse the object here
by saying outer fixture this doesn't
even have to be fixture by the way this
could be outer anything I'm gonna break
my code by doing this for instance but
you don't the name it fixture in this
case and then I have my code so when I
run this Python I put the wrong place so
CD my library CD
yeah so I'm just out here CP dot slash
solve okay just gonna use a GUI okay um
hi test my library test this should run
oh no all right Tracy yeah there you go
it runs twice if I would do minus V
you'll see both tests come up this this
one runs really fast in two seconds so
what I'm gonna do is so the code looks
like it looks like this right now I'm
using a fixture so here's me using a
fixture it takes point two oh two
seconds to run if I took the fixture out
and I can die instantiated this twice
like like this so what I didn't want you
to do this is why I'm just trying to
show you you could write the test like
this and then say adder and then I they
say adder here and I get rid of it so
now here's my code does anyone want to
take a guess how long it would take to
run yeah it'd take it over a minute
because it's going to instantiate once
and it'll be fast but this one's gonna
wait a minute before it tests can run
this we can you can see that the first
ones gonna run and then we're gonna be
standing here for a minute while this
thing still goes that's the point of
fixtures this is a little bit more of a
contrived example this one ran in five
seconds because I modified my module
here to be 5 but in real life example is
you guys work with data dating loading
data takes a long time for really big
data sets do not do it more than once
besides wasting time when you're in it
actually puts a huge load on the
so my coworker did this he he ran he was
running tests but he was just hitting
the database every time and then the
DJ's got really angry with him because
he was hitting a like he was just
slamming the database with queries every
like second to get a crap ton of data
out to do his tests and he's like Oh
everything's fine it's running my
computer but like this the server was
like on fire so you know you don't don't
do it
besides wasting your own time you're
gonna piss off somebody that has to run
like the spark cluster or whatever that
you're running on so don't they just use
a fixture load it once and then you're
being like sort of responsible with
usage that's my sage advice to you
that's what the data portion comes in
we're going to go through I'll do sit
I'm gonna skip to the skip the end and
skip back a little bit we're gonna
definitely run out of time before I get
to how monkey patch works but here's I
will be at this conference
all three days so if you guys want to go
through it you can just come find me and
I will be happy to walk through any of
this code with you any time so we can go
through there you can you have my
contact information - you can send me a
message and I'll try and help you out so
yeah don't feel if you feel confused
don't leave this conference feeling that
way
come find me we'll talk through it like
the toilet oh I'm not like gonna be a
really mean person after this lecture
ends you can we can still still chat so
let's do mock I'm gonna explain how mock
works so let's go back to mark example
since I have github up let's just used
by that example oops
computer doesn't want to cooperate all
right well great
so are we load things locally
okay so Mach lets you create fakes fake
stuff in Python fake objects the reason
being is some of an object everything in
Python is an object you just might have
heard that means that like with data
frames there's all these a little dot
methods I'll let you do cool things like
rolling sums or whatever they might be
but it's really complicated sometimes
that you create these objects like
creating a data frame sometimes isn't
easy you got a little whole bunch of
stuff but you want to just test one
piece of this entire thing out what mock
lets you do is basically fake out the
majority the object and just add in the
little things that you that you need and
let's go through I'll show you an
example oh I'll give you three world
real world examples to motivate this
when you fit a model if you have to fit
up a model and then you want to call dot
like dot predict and scikit-learn dot
predict takes to function it takes
probably an x and a y and it gives you
an output if you have to fit an entire
model just to test that your dot predict
works you're gonna be waiting like
you're wasting all that time fitting
that model you just want to make sure
this like one tiny thing works why do
you have to do all these steps
beforehand that's an example where you
use mock you don't want to test that the
whole model fits you just want to test
that your dot predict does something it
doesn't totally fail out and maybe in
this case you're got predict fails when
you input a string you don't have to fit
a whole model just check that your dot
predict doesn't take a string another
example is calling the API alright you
don't always have a bazillion dollars to
pay Google to call the API a thousand
times so I have two students here that
wear my bootcamp they part of my class
they were hitting an API and then all of
them hit a rate limit within like the
first thirty minutes and they couldn't
use the API anymore so testing against a
real API is expensive usually someone's
gonna charge you money for it so what
you can do is you can mock the API
response which is what the next example
is so you can test against something
that's not the real API so when you get
to relay fail you're pretty sure it
works and then my example is calling a
database that I call databases a lot of
work if I'm testing against a real
database somebody's gonna be really
angry at me then I'm opening connection
zillion times to test a tiny thing out
so let's go through an example of mock
so in my library I have I have a module
um and in this case I test that a data
frame is over if it's if the data frame
is over a million rows
looks like it's it's big otherwise if
it's less than a million Rosita return
false so I want to make sure that I
might is is dataframe big object it
works now here's a trick if I want to
test this out and I have to make a data
frame that's a million like Y and we can
actually just make this even more
ridiculous if I have to do this this is
gonna be super expensive like I'd have
to generate a data frame that's like
this case looks like multi billions
shape Y just to make sure this function
works that's what that's really annoying
so what I can do is I can create I can
import mock and we'll go through the
import in a second but I can create this
mock thing and then I can just give it
an attribute that's huge and then I can
see what the function is so this is not
a data frame this is a mock and then I
can add something to a mom so I'm gonna
show you outside of the context that is
test real quick just to make it a little
more clear so ipython so from this one
you get it from from pipe pythons
inbuilt unit tests a unit test mock
import mock and I can say equals mock
and the AAE equals mock
so I'm instantiating a mock object here
and if I can say a dot name it's nothing
but I can say it nine equals like test
and now I can do a dot name well that's
a test I can do a dot shape equals two
and 1000 and now when I do a dot shape I
get that back it's basically just like
this a more first thing that we can just
shove attributes on to see what happens
you can make another mouth cops gotta do
this all the time you can do mock return
value equals hello we return value now
when I do this it acts like a function
that returns something so now I don't
have to run in the entire function I can
just fake out a function by having this
mock objects so mock is a specially
designed object and it's in pythons
inbuilt unit test that that is complete
built to be this like I don't know you
guys my Pokemon did oh you did oh did it
can be any Pokemon this is like the the
ditto of Python objects where it can be
any object so you can just slide it in
and that way you don't have to deal with
something expensive
in our particular case we I do not want
to make it any frame that's like 20
billion integers long just the test that
my big function works because that's a
huge waste of time what I'm just going
to do is that I'm just going to say that
the shape is big and then I'm just going
to test that this is true and then this
is false any any have a question why I'm
doing this oh yeah actually good point
that would have failed good catch that
would've been fun so mark is just this
thing that you can just make it act like
anything else you can tell it what to do
it's the most nice of Python objects
that will just that'll just take any
attribute or return any value and just
sort of sub in and act anything we want
yeah you think yes so I should say is
Marcus an object that will act any way
you want it to act in this case I want
when I when I ask it what its shape is
its gonna tell me this number and this
is gonna to this function the way that
this is gets a little bit more in the
way Python works but this for all this
function is doing is it's calling it's
seeing what the shape object is and then
seeing if the if the rowcount
weight yeah row count is is bigger than
two million I don't need a full data
frame to dismiss function I just need
something that looks like a data frame
because python is what it's called duck
types this is a whole statically type is
ductile Python is duck type which means
that it's Python doesn't check that all
the attributes exist before you test and
so it makes it easy to make either sort
of testing where I give it an object
that looks like the data frame and it's
just happy and it like life goes on it's
the the CS like 300 way of saying that
does it make sense why I'm not creating
a data frame yeah okay so I'm gonna run
this test
yes so that's a good point
you better really know what your thing
is supposed to act like because if you
don't and you create the wrong Mach that
you're not actually testing what's gonna
happen so this requires this requires
you to know how your code works that's a
really yeah I've done that before I've
had mocks and then I'm like wow my codes
great there's somebody use it like your
code sucks and then I'm like oh nobody
tested it and like your tests are wrong
like shoot no that's embarrassing so yes
you have to you have to actually know
how your code is gonna work so I'll run
this for you real quick and then we're
gonna go through the mock example and
then I'm gonna do questions so Python my
library tests work no up because I made
my mistake not Python should be PI test
and then of course I run into my own
problems maybe this is what happens when
I do live coding did I have it right
before it well
oh I know why sad okay this example
definitely is broken so let me see I'm
gonna see if I can fix it in a minute
otherwise I'm just gonna say we're gonna
do the example yeah I think actually is
what it is is because I call I call a
magic so this is a good example I
screwed up on my mark and now the tests
fail and now I look like an idiot in my
own Python to toriel so this is a really
good example the dangers of testing I
know I know what the areas is gonna take
me more than a minute that's all for now
all you guys except that mock does the
thing that it does I'll let you try
doing the example and I'll show you the
solution which I do believe works so
I'll give you I'll give you a like three
four or five minutes to just try out the
mock object so see if you want to try
out number nine and then we'll run the
solution and I will talk through it
there I apologize
on your computer work oh yeah maybe I
hear I'll just try that okay get
checkout dot yeah this is sometimes it's
nice to have slides because then you
really can't mess up slides but this is
a good example for testing right I
actually screwed up my code in the
middle of my talk and then my test told
me that I screw up my code so maybe this
is a it's like I don't know it's like
those those videos you seen YouTube of
people on bikes crashing into things and
you're like I should wear helmets like
oh yeah okay so yeah I did screw up my
code when I modified it so there was an
accident a little explanation of testing
I thought I was doing something that if
I would work and then it clearly didn't
work and then PI tests told me that it
didn't work so the the example on github
works the one that you see in the video
is the one that doesn't work as we saw
with the PI test so there is a good
example testing for the win I'll give
you till 250 and then I'm gonna cut it
off and I'll take questions
okay
mm-hm
so we're trying to fail you for mock is
so I'm unit tests for mark and you do
mock our return value equals forty here
oh I have this I have to put this in
yeah so you can say see series equals
mock and then you can say series dots
dots sum equals mock return value equals
forty so you're using two so in this
case there's two objects there's a
series of check and then there's this
some object that does something so you
can this can be multiple layers deep
alright so in the interest of time I'm
going to talk to the solution that I
hopefully works sure does but that's
going to find out
so you can do this two ways I showed one
way and I'll run I'll see it let's see
if we can like for the other without
making a mistake so let me try it real
quick I test my library tests so there's
two ways you can do this this is getting
a question you can you can say a series
as a mock object so I'm marking it out
and then series dot some dot return
values 2000 mock does this this thing
where if you call a dot and you don't
tell what it is it just creates another
mock object and then it gives you the
Train value the other way you can do
this you can say series dot sum equals
mock and then the return value in this
case I'm going to call this return value
equal one so these two end up doing the
equivalent thing I can either I can
either this case I guess I didn't
explain it well but I know that I know
the way mock works and if you just call
dot and then this it returns another
mock object and then I can set the
return value manually myself this way or
I can create a mock object I can assign
this object to be another mock object
that returns the return value I know
this is getting like Inception like but
I mean this this is uh this is pretty
reasonable and test this happens all the
time
okay I'd you mark that shape or you can
do that so you need whatever mocks will
take on whatever attribute you give oh
oh yeah so I will give another
disclaimer this maybe I screwed up this
example I believe I I did make an error
on so what I'm gonna do is don't use it
don't use this as the actual example I
will right after this talk I will fix
this and I'll pushes the github so it is
100% correct it works but there's
there's a reason why it works but it
shouldn't work that way would so for now
example eight that you've seen on this
on these slides please just ignore
there's an error on it I will push right
out for this tutorial a completely
correct version this this solve version
actually is
100% the other one was assigning an
attribute to a modular level namespace
which wasn't which is actually using a
mock object it's the mock module so
that's why I made the yes the mistake so
this is a really good example of me
writing a tutorial and then screwing it
up and it works but they're still
bugging my code this is I don't know I
can't explain it I would I didn't do
that on purpose that's actually just
what happened so this is why you should
test because we make mistakes and
testing helps you I catch mistakes most
of the time usually all the time but and
this is this is also why we still do
code reviews by the way so there's
testing and this code reviews it's for
both aspects mm-hmm yeah you can assign
an object return value so python is a
crazy language and that like everything
is an object and objects can return
other objects and functions or objects
and like the whole world is objects
which is not true of every language if
you work with other languages like C or
even are not everything is an object in
our like our has integers and they're
just integers but in Python integers are
objects I know this is like this is far
off computer science but when if you
start writing a lot of Python code these
things like start matter because that's
how the language itself functions all
right with that I'm just gonna leave it
open to just any general questions that
you guys have at all for 9 minutes I
don't want to take up the whole time
talking you usually shouldn't write
tests that depend on tests because then
if one test fails you don't know which
one is the failure the up the upstream
test the downstream test so while you
could is usually frowned upon because
it's just like it then it becomes really
hard to tell what's going on so one of
the values of doing unit tests if you're
reading small is that only one test will
fail and then you know where the errors
in your code if you write tests that
were found on tests I'll depend on tests
suddenly your test is running through
like 10,000 lines of code and the all of
them will blow out and you can't tell
what's on fire there doesn't make sense
so yeah
sometimes you want to ideally yeah it's
it's fair so this is just this is just
how you decide to code there's some
Pierce that's a unit test should be to
be unit eyes there's tiny as possible
you test one function and they're
completely unlike right a bazillion unit
tests and mock everything but that means
you write a lot of test code and write a
lot of mocks and the nice thing is then
you get really isolated test to test one
time specific thing some people are like
why don't I just test my whole function
at once so why don't I just call my
model fit and just that's the entire
model and then see if I get the correct
prediction and then in that case yeah
it's easier cuz you wrote one test and
you're testing all your code in one shot
but if you get an error it's hard to
tell where it goes I'm like somewhere in
the middle and RV's where like right in
between we test our entire plot function
of like 100 lines of code and we think
that's close enough so it just depends
on where you're where you're at
yeah that's a great-looking example how
do you split up test requirements and EV
requirements let's just go look at our
B's because it has it so I'm just gonna
keep using RVs because I know it very
well we have we do we have regular
requirements so requirements of txt so
if you want to use RVs this is your
dependencies and if you want to develop
on RVs then you also install the
development which is all these other
things so we split up we split alone
yeah we split apart and our B's we split
up our our dev requirements from our
regular requirement so the to go one
level deeper there's people that just
use a library they don't need they don't
need PI tests because you're just
running the library but then there's
people that are developing and arteries
and then you do need PI tests because we
make that a requirement of development
so I don't want everyone who uses our
reason to stop high test it's kind of a
waste of time but I do want everyone
that develops of what I receive by test
I should say we if you look at our
pandas and things they should be
gracefully
this is a hard question because I'm just
like so much less familiar with testing
in the libraries because they don't
strongly develop another libraries
I'd say the bigot oh I know actually
here's a big one so python requires more
tests in my opinion then actually a for
a fact then like c-sharp and whatnot
because in c-sharp because they're
statically compiled you get interface
checks by by the compliation themselves
so the code doesn't compile that itself
is a test that the code works with
python and even javascript because their
duck type you don't know what an object
is until you run it so you end up with
more I end up with more tests at chests
that interface exists and that the
object types are the types that I want
versus in c-sharp you know I don't test
for that because it's like a or Scala I
can only be that one thing because it's
just it's in the definition of the code
so make sense so just test to make sure
my code runs or my code does the thing I
wanted to do in the other in all
languages but in Python I definitely
check interfaces and types so in data
science a lot I have to make sure like
integers are integers they're not floats
that strings are actually strings and
then there's Python to Python 3 so I
have to double check that in Python 2
it's it's the correct string type
because there's there's differences
between Z languages all that well Python
2 and Python 3 or 2 different languages
so I have to make sure that the string
type is different
three Xena codes Python twos blanking at
the top my head but it's the string
handling is not the same yes it's really
cool if you use Python three six which a
lot of them don't so then we can so we
read a lot of testing RVs because we
have support three five and PI EMC still
supports two seven which doesn't have
like type in thing at all so then you
can't but to your point like if everyone
was on three six are higher than instead
of having the right as many tests to
test the type of objects you can just
have the the linter like my pike try and
verify that it's not type but it's
important another they called type hints
because we're not guarantee they're just
hints so that's still not a sit still
just because they have hints doesn't
make it a strongly type of language it's
a good question yeah no it's a good
question so there's a your the question
was do you always have to do tests that
are that is this thing a boolean or not
no there's other types of tests and I'm
gonna see if I can find one really quick
yeah see if otherwise okay
in this one we're not testing and we're
in this particular function we're
testing that a value error is raised so
where the question was I'm in Mic
functions I'm just checking that like in
our outer function we're checking that
two equals two then we also had a
question should I check string types
when an outer function I wouldn't want
to check that an exception is raised if
you pass in a string you can write a
test that is if if you input a string do
you I get a value type error or here or
whatever the case might be so you can
test for exceptions too it's not just
conditional testing things you can also
test logs I can test this logs I can't
that files are written so you can write
tested to make sure that your your
program is writing things on the
director on the file this a file system
so if they do sense a lot I dumped excel
files I don't actually write a thousand
Excel files I just want to make sure
that it would write a thousand Excel
files so I can write a test that checks
that a thousand Excel files would have
been written which is not necessarily
like a boolean but I checked that like a
another thing would have happened also a
good question yes most open-source
projects will say run will want you to
write tests nearly all of them will this
is the only way open-source works
because if people just checked in code
like every library would have we broken
all the time just for a fact like you
guys have written code yourself like you
start writing and there's gonna be bugs
and if you check that in then everyone's
installation of pandas are broken and
worldly on fire
so every library usually wants you to
write tests because they want to make
sure that you're validating the
functionality road and you're not your
library still runs and isn't gonna break
everyone's pip install pandas so yes
that's another really good reason to
test all major I'm gonna sit down and
say all major and stable open-source
libraries are gonna require testing and
most companies require testing
internally to most companies don't like
the critical package is breaking like
right before the end of the financial
quarter so I can imagine that a couple a
couple of people here have companies
that are asking them to write tests you
don't really you guys any more questions
they're all really good completely out
of time
[Applause]